can some of these state lockdown
measures go too far well in a dozen
states and cities across the country
with these protests they say yeah they
have that they want to get back to doing
what they want to do but no less the
Attorney General the United States says
that some states do indeed go too far
and he can picture taking legal action
against them if they don't change their
ways
whatever that means Andy McCarthy is the
former assistant US attorney on again
interpreting what he said is risky for
me I'm no lawyer and you're a great one
is he saying that if governors add on or
do things that go beyond what they
originally intended is he focusing on
those or or what Neal what he's saying
is that when the government regulates
your fundamental rights which include
your right of free association free
exercise of religion your right to work
in many ways they have to narrowly
tailor their restrictions so that it's
the least restrictive way of burdening
your fundamental right and the Justice
Department has already intervened in a
case in Greenville Mississippi on behalf
of religious believers who were being
denied the right to do communal
observance of Easter so it's not like
this is a threat in the air this is
something they've already done and I
think the most important thing he said
Neal especially for what you've been
covering today is it's not your burden
as an American to show that your job is
essential it's their burden that is the
government's burden to show that your
job can't be operated safely before they
can shut it down and as we move to this
phase one I think that's going to be
very important but a lot of these
governors that were led know less but
the president itíd States who
recommended these you know stay-at-home
provisions you know not as you know
robustly as some of the governor's I
grant you argue it is our job to kind of
keep you safe and not put you in harm's
way or risk your life or others so when
these protesters gather
in indict crowds of the rest are they
actually doing a disservice to their
very protest and and what is a
governor's responsibility there yeah
well the thing is Neil they have
multiple responsibilities one interest
that the state has is public health the
other interest the state has or an other
interest the main reason the state was
created was to protect the liberties and
the fundamental freedoms of Americans
and those things clash I think what the
Attorney General is saying is you know
at the first phase of a crisis it makes
every bit of good sense to ratchet up
the restrictions till we can get our
arms around what we're dealing with
but you continually have an obligation
to tailor the restrictions down as you
move from phase to phase and what what
he's saying is we're now moving from the
bend the curve phase to the reopening
the economy phase you're still gonna
have this clash of rights but the
government has to tell her their
restrictions down but they're also
risking potential lives or spiking cases
and I know this is something that you
know the framers the Constitution could
never have envisioned I get that but
where do you balance that that.oh
between life and livelihood yeah well
what what he said and I think this is
right now is that it's the nature of
executive power that they have a lot of
power in order to restrict where it's
necessary to restrict on behalf of
public health but it's also flexible
federal power and it's like the flexible
executive power between the states and
the federal government and the idea is
that there's no magic formula because
the situation's dynamic and a good
executive has to continually react to
the changing conditions and the changing
goals if they have tamp down here if
they have bent the curve and we're going
to try to reopen the economy they have
to regulate with that in the front of
their minds with that and that
improvement of that curve and then clear
proof of that now the discrepancy seems
to be thank you very much is how long
that curve has to last